Philippe est éducateur sportif son lieu
de travail c'est ce camion le mobile
sport depuis plusieurs semaines il
sillonne les routes du département
du matériel d'athlétisme on a aussi du
matériel de raquette des sports
collectifs ça c'est ce qu'on appelle du
flag rugby donc c'est du rugby
accessible à tout le monde et en fait la
différence aujourd'hui c'est que il y a
pas de placage on attrape des petits
mots qui sont accrochés à la ceinture le
sport partout et pour tous c'est ce que
souhaite le comité départemental du
sport en milieu rural des Yvelines à
l'origine du mobile sport en mettant en
circulation ce camion itinérant son
objectif et d'amener l'activité physique
et sportive dans les territoires qui
n'ont pas d'équipements de structure ou
encore d'encadrement le but c'est
d'aller là-bas d'amener le matériel et
de proposer avec la personne qui conduit
le camion qui est à diplômé le sport on
n'est pas là pour faire de la
concurrence à qui que ce soit on est
simplement là vraiment pour pallier à un
manque qui a été
identifié et pouvoir permettre à tout le
monde en fait de trouver le juste milieu
et pour intervenir avec différents à
différents moments de la journée
j'espère il est important pour pour la
santé dans un premier temps mais pas que
pour la santé il est aussi important
pour l'esprit et pouvoir s'aérer aller
dans différents endroits serrer l'esprit
c'est ça régénère aussi notre corps en
lui-même mairie association école
communauté d'entreprise ou encore
particulier le mobile sport s'adresse à
un large public il propose une
cinquantaine d'activités adaptables pour
les enfants adultes seniors et personne
en situation de handicap on répond à une
demande on évalue si vraiment il y a
qu'est-ce qu'il manque réellement
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont besoin comment on
peut travailler ensemble et puis après
le jour J bah c'est parti quoi on a des
prix qui sont attractifs enfin on n'est
pas on est totalement différent on n'est
pas une entreprise en fait on n'est pas
là pour faire du chiffre on est là
vraiment pour rendre service aux gens et
c'est pour ça que on veut rendre le
sport accessible à tous et le fait de se
déplacer leur permet déjà de faire du
sport 30000 euros de matériels ont été
investis
le pari financé par une dizaine de
partenaires dont le département
aujourd'hui il se déplaçait
essentiellement dans le sud des Yvelines